hello and welcome to the second day
of nbc oslo i hope everyone had a
wonderful first day
and while i can't be with you all in
person today i'm really looking forward
to sharing the next hour with you
and this will be where we'll look to
solve a question facing
many api developers and that is how do
we choose between
graphql grpc and rest
so to get to the answer that question
we're going to do
quite a number of things so we're going
to start off
by looking to gain a common
understanding
of the api styles that have evolved over
time
we'll then look at software architecture
and look
at system properties and the constraints
or decisions that then
defiled or yields those properties
with that base knowledge we're then
going to look at a number of
conversations that are happening in the
api industry today
and see if we can apply this this
learning of this logic
to some of the statements that lack some
nuance or
some constructive element and then
finally we're going to bring this all
together
and look at some sample scenarios that
you may face
to make it more concrete should you
choose to use one of these api
technologies when you
either have a personal project or bring
it back to your office
so before we proceed um a little bit
about myself
so my name is rob crowley i am the head
of engineering for a company called vixx
and we build automotive fare collection
systems so
similar to the card in london or we work
with router in oslo as well
before that i was a consultant for a
number of years
including telstra purple or redefine in
australia and the vast amount of my
career has
been in building and designing
distributed systems
so apis are a subject that are very
close to my head
i'm also the co-organizer of dd perth
western australia's
largest conference and last year we had
over 800 attendees so that's really been
a massive success
and i'm also available on the socials at
rob d
crowley and this is a talk
that i've been giving various versions
of
for about a year now and the genesis was
really some of the
challenges that i was not only
personally facing
but also my clients and the companies
that i worked with
and while that might sound rather
altruistic there was a slightly selfish
element
to it as well and that was really a
reflection that
my twitter timeline was really an
absolute
tire fire and you might ask why is that
well when i first joined twitter it was
really about the same time that i
started to get into apis in a serious
way
and rest was the on vogue api start at
the time so i started following
many of the luminaries in the industry
such as
mike amensing or eric wilde
and i know the huge amount from these
people and
it was wonderful about three to four
years and then 2015 came around
and facebook released graphql and
i started following a whole host of new
people
and the problem was these two groups of
didn't often agree so one tweet could
then yield 15 or 16
rebuttals or counter arguments but many
of these counter arguments were very
black
x is better than y or y breaks
this i found it very difficult to then
take that
information or take that statement and
then apply it to the problems that i was
facing
so what sharing a small a small example
of what i saw there so back in 2019
on may 25th actually my birthday i saw
this
tweet and i was like it's 2019. you
should learn graphql this is very much
the same
time i was playing around quite a lot
with the real time subscriptions
elements of dracula
i said absolutely this is something that
we should have available to us
so i agree with them quickly aaron he's
one of my good friends but i have
one of the cloud advocates at microsoft
it's just fancy oh data and that again
is one of the playful exchange
we do see more serious versions of that
going around
and i would like to comment that
actually this weekend aaron will be
building
an app with graphql so i think in the
long run i might well have one
but it's not just happening on twitter
so if we look at some of the blog posts
that have been shared
as i say sort of back in 2017
so a couple of years after gradual
last release and there was really
a sense there that it would completely
eclipse
rest and this particular article says
rest is the new soap in other words we
don't need it anymore instead
defunct and i think i found this quite
confronting because
i had spent the last 10 years of my
career learning
rest apis and learning how to build
affected how to design
resources and workflows is all this
learning now
defaults not required and this isn't an
isolated article
in there another one from about the same
time
declared rest apis are rest in peace
long live graphql i get more sentiment
from the community
that there was only one way to build
api's moving forward
i personally didn't see that that was
the case and i saw many of the clients
that were working with
had the same problems they were facing
the same challenges
and it wasn't just these conversations i
had this
sense of deja vu when i read a lot of
these articles
and i couldn't help but feel that we've
actually
been here before so if that's
what was happening in 2017 let's
wind the clock back a little bit further
and we'll go back to 2010
and in this case we could see the same
sort of
articles but this time declaring rest
being in the ascendancy
and soap again going out of favor
and this one that says soap is
officially dead long addressed
and the unfortunate truth is a huge
number of percentage of the apis we deal
with today in production
there's still soap based while it might
be on both to build
new apis using that today if we have
other choices
it is definitely not dead and many of us
are still supporting
apis in many different technologies
but what can we really take away from
this so
if something's date and rest is the new
soul
does that mean gracky the numerous
surely not that couldn't be the case it
wouldn't make any sense
but lo and behold yes it is apparently
graphql is
one i'm not sure if there was ever a
product too
but if there is please let me know
so what can we actually learn from these
exchanges the first thing that we would
have seen is that they're all very
black and white they all have one view
and don't
really take in a lot of possibility for
a long time
so maybe we can dismiss all of this and
simply say
maybe we just don't like xml and we get
on with them we look at different
challenges
but to do that i feel would miss
a very important point and that is that
many of our api consumers the very
people we build apis form
and again something that's close to my
heart is we build apis for other
developers
so many developers are unsatisfied and
frustrated with the api's experiences
that
we're experiencing or receiving and also
our api community is very small
we need to work together so we can't
really afford to have
these camps with different ideologies or
different needs around sets of
technologies
so what i'm really hoping from today's
talk is that i can
give you a necessary foundation of
understanding that you will be able to
take a balanced approach
to choosing the api's technologies and
styles for the problems at hand
and maybe that sounds a tiny bit
idealistic maybe a tiny bit of a dreamer
so we could imagine that there's no
protocols
it's not hard to do maybe there's no
hypermedia hills to die on no movement
types we don't have to worry about
contracts
wouldn't that be wonderful unfortunately
not
that's not how apis work
apis are required to allow two persons
that are otherwise distributed to
communicate
effectively we will never get away from
having to have shared semantics and also
shared syntax so you cannot just
understand
what's meant by the message but also how
to decode
and encode that message so we have to
have standards and protocols
so this is a problem that we need to
face into
so let's see a little bit about how
these technologies or styles have
evolved over time so i'll take us all
back
to 1991 and we'll start with
corban so a middleware language and at
the point in time
this was really seen to be the future
of e-commerce on the web
unfortunately for some it actually fell
out of favor
for xml of all things
moving forward to 1993 we had remote
data access
so a client server approach where a
client
could then query data from a remote
database
so it sounds very like a query syntax
and it was and we'll see some
similarities in that approach
as we see some future api styles and
technologies
so moving forward into 1998 we had a
formal specification
of xml arrogancy and rbc stands for
remote procedure call
and it is a term coined by bruce nelson
and up until this point rpc was
an approach but there wasn't a
specification around it
so in 1998 we had a formal specification
between rpc
over xl in
1999 don box and
four others from microsoft that name don
box might be familiar as
the man behind the four tenants of soa
and they released so so again a heavily
rpc based technology
which then used a wisdom as the
contract that would then format the
exchange between the client and the
server
in the year 2000 roy fielding released a
senal dissertation
about rest and this was really about
building apis that didn't
work off at all against the web but
really embraced it
so how can we build apis that are
sympathetic and embrace
the underlying protocol and this is
mainly for the purposes of the apis
we'll be talking about today http
moving forward to 2005 and in this
period rest
really begins to rise to the ascendancy
in the apis that we're building
and we still have our pc but at this
time we've seen
xml give way to to jason
and that's really keeping in sync with
what we saw with the move to rest as
well
moving forward to 2007 we had odata
another technology released by microsoft
under the marker of a better way to rest
and this really embraced a lot of the
ideas
of remote data access where it provides
a rich query syntax for the clients
to define exactly the data that it needs
from the server
so instead of a uniform interface
constraint which defines a canonical url
for each
resource and in which we will then
receive a representation
back from the server this then provides
a huge amount of data to the client
to define exactly what it wants in the
shape
so moving forward from 2007 to 2015
gratie well
lands on the scene and again this is
really about empowering
clients to receive only the data that it
wants
and avoid some of the perceived
inefficiencies
around rest
and then in 2016 we've got the latest
incarnation
of grpc and that is again
our pc going back all the ways we saw
back in corvo in 1991
and while the approach remain consistent
we've seen the implementation of the
technologies change over time
so that's the technologies themselves
what can we see that has been happening
in parallel within
industry so
in the early 2000s we were really
building apis
for specific partners and they were
still pipe integration so one-to-one
one client go to one server and it's a
discrete integration
this really changed with web 2.0
starting in
2010 when companies like
twitter and facebook start building
public apis
and these are apis where one server can
support
multiple different clients but instead
of
being built for one specific client it's
more of a
conformist api if you aware of eric
evans and the mainstream design
where they don't take into account
individual client needs but rather the
final interface which
we all conform to and this has really
been the prevalent style for public apis
for the last decade
and then where are we going to see
happening next so there's quite a lot of
people in the industry saying that
the next wave will likely be autonomous
apis
so rich lattices of apis that will then
be composed to
achieve higher order business needs and
this will be underpinned by technologies
like serverless as well which reduces
the footprint
and will move to a more worth-based
model for
apis but this is still some ways off and
the majority of us will still be in the
second wave of generic apis particularly
if we're building
public facing apis or apis for multiple
internal teams within your organization
so across all of these technologies
while they might appear
relatively different on the face of it
they all share a surprising number of
commonalities so we have flat file
apis so an example of this might be
electronic data interchange
and what might sound antiquated it is a
perfectly
valid and in fact ideal choice if you
were doing large batch operations
this is maybe month-end reporting and
instead of sending a paper-based file
between two companies
you can do that electronically to a
defined format
and if that's about style apis the
complete antithesis of that is a
streaming api
where we're constantly exchanging data
between the clients and the server
and that could be stockpile changes or
it could be
video or data streaming
we have our pc apis so
most recently brought to the four game
by grpc
where with an rpc api we are effectively
treating the distributed call almost as
if the network was not there
so we're treating it at a higher order
and we're trying to keep the semantics
of that higher order language as well
with the web api how we call and consume
data is very
different so instead of using classes
that abstract away
the network we actually spin up a http
client we embrace the web we send http
methods to define again
what operations we would want again to
specific urls so we're really embracing
the
web with that and that's the major
change or difference between
experience recording and consuming an
rpc or a web api
i'll ignore the semantic or design
changes
for this particular point in the tool
and it might be a challenging message to
hear
first thing on the second day of nbc
oslo but
there is no single best apr
style computing is hard building apis
is challenging what i can say though
is there is absolutely a best api style
for your problem and that is really the
purpose of today's
tool to arm you with the information
required
that you can first define the
or identify the appropriate style
and then the technology for your own
problem at hand
so how what might we go about
being able to inform ourselves about
this decision
and we can take some guidance from roy
fielding
he said that the properties are induced
by the set of constraints within an
architecture
so in other words the design choices
that we make
will then yield certain characteristics
of the
solution and when we think of
constraints
we often just think of technology
constraints but there's many types that
we really need to consider
to build an effective product
there's business constraints so
anything that really affects the
profitability of
a company or business in them so that
could be
time financial budget
and this could be across your customer
your own business
or certain product requirements maybe
you just looking to have a very
perishable window of opportunity
and that's a set say is it yourself for
maybe time constraints on what
there's technical constraints so
embracing
all the challenges of distributed
computing so we have the eighth
fallacies so
the network is not reliable latency is
not zero
so what are all the things we need to do
to support maybe the security concerns
or debate that we're facing
but also how we need to be able to
evolve the system over time
and the final and probably the most
interesting set of constraints
is all around the operation of that
service
and this is really all the
socio-technical or the human
constraints around so how are we going
to support or build
this system is there multiple teams
within an organization buildings
in which case then looking at convoy's
normal which states that
the systems we build will be a mirror of
the communication pattern
between our teams so
these are things that have become very
close to my heart and my current role
where i'm looking to align the operating
model again with the product lines that
we're looking to build
and it's not just about organizing teams
but it's also about the set of knowledge
or expertise within your teams
so for instance rest to build an
effective rest api
requires deep expertise in http
if you don't have it you will struggle
to be able to get the most out of that
lifestyle so again really looking at all
of the elements around your teams how
they're organizing the knowledge they
have
to drive some of these decisions as well
and so when we take all of those
constraints
either business technical or
socio-technical
they will then yield the properties of
the system
and that would be the properties of the
software system itself
but also the wider ecosystem everything
around the operation
of that product and when i'm designing a
system
i always start with the properties
i define the characteristics that the
system needs to have
or the properties it needs to display
and then i work backwards to say what
constraints
or decisions can i make that will then
yield those properties
so it's always a case of defining what
you need
and then working back it's definitely
not a case
of starting with a technology and hoping
it will fit your problem
so how might we gain some insight into
being able to do this in practice and
again
roy fielding has some interesting
guidance
for us in this case he says
that while there's never an optimal
architecture style for
every application we
can start comparing architectural styles
for the properties induced and this was
really the
original premise for this talk
and i was slightly dismayed to learn
five minutes into
my research for us is that someone else
has actually done it so zen academic
gave this talk or a very similar
detailed
a review of rest and graphql in
the end of 2018 at nordic api's
conference
and it goes into quite a lot of detail
about the
pros and cons of different api styles
particularly
in terms of arrest which i would say
he's he started with and then started to
compare graphql with
um it is a very insightful talk um
i'll include a link to it in the
references that i'll share at the end
but it doesn't cover grpc so over the
course of the
of the next one we'll we'll weave in
some of the insights that
democrats but then also update
where we've sort of seen over the last
16 months 18 months since he gave that
talk
as well so instead we're going to look
at something that's a little bit more
fun
so we're going to look at some of the
conversations that have been happening
in the api industry over
the last sort of year and a year and a
bit and then we're going to for each of
those statements we're going to
take the next level of detail to it and
then start spilling
dispelling some of those myths and at
the same time using these as the
vehicles for
comparing different aspects of these of
these api styles
and showing where some shine and where
others don't
so let's tackle the initial ones that i
mentioned at the start of this tool and
that is the
the statement that rest in peace apis
that rest apis are rest in peace apis
and not only graphql
or as another person puts it graphql
will do to rest
what jason did to xml
but they're blanket statements and they
don't let us know
why or any context of supporting that
statement
so let's start by looking at some of the
thinking that underpins these api styles
so graphql on the read side so where the
client is querying data
from the server looks very like rda
to remote data access it affords a huge
amount of power to the client
to request the data and only the data it
needs
however on the right side
it uses our pc and that's for the
mutations
so that's again a right or subscriptions
which are an event-based way of getting
real-time data
so we can see actually that graphql
heavily builds
on the api styles and previous
approaches and in fact it's also got a
fair amount of http
semantics woven into it as well
so let's compare graphql then to grpc
a grpc is quite different graphql
and rest are both protocol agnostic
whereas
grpc is firmly tied to html2
not http1.x but specifically http 2
to support multiplexing across a single
connection
and this is really where grpc is
focusing on
is about performance so again being able
to have
very performant real-time interactions
across
different distributed components
and if http 2 is the protocol grpc
then uses protobuf or protocol buffers
for both the contract the interface
definition language
so in the case of soap this was whistle
or in the case of a graphql api
that is the graphql schema and in rest
it could be
an open api initiative contract or
rammel or apu blueprints so it uses
protocol buffers for both the contracts
but also as the data exchange format
across the wire so how we
encode and decode data
and the rest is something very different
again so
if grpc and
graphql are data over
http rest is really a state machine
over http and when i say
state machine what i really mean is
workflow
so it could be a business process which
based on
what stage in the process you were you
could have multiple different actions of
paths
and state machines then are driven by
an aspect of the uniform interface
constraint which is
hypermedia and hypermedia is often one
of the things that we struggle
to understand in a
rest api or how we can build those
affordances into our responses but it's
actually a concept that many of us are
already familiar with
so if we take a look at this very basic
web page what we can see is there's
actually a number of hyperlink
installed already we have
an image tag an anchor tag and a form
and all of these controls have
well-defined semantics
which then allow any browser to consume
this page
and know what to do with the data so an
image tag
when the browser receives that it will
de-reference the resource that is
mentioned at that url and it will then
display that within the allocated space
when you click on an anchor tag that
link will be dereferenced
and you will be navigated to that
particular page
and with a form when you submit that
form
all the data will then be packaged up
and sent to the server
i talk a lot about hypermedia because i
do feel it is absolutely foundational to
do a little best api
and while we often see it at the top of
the
student majority model at level three
for me it's either rest or it's not and
that is defined by whether it is
or not so hypermedia is the end of the
application i don't need this to be a
confronting
message i apologize if it is but i
firmly believe
that where we don't embrace
hypermedia we end up with a lot of
rest-ish apis
that are difficult to consume but also
require a fair amount of
knowledge to build and i firmly believe
that in many cases those apis
would be able to be built more
effectively or deliver a better
experience maybe using one of those
other styles if again from a
socio-technical district we don't have
the
knowledge to be able to get the most out
of that style
so really don't build restish apis
there are many options that we have
available and
many different constraints that will
then be able to yield the best
outcome for our consumers which is
really the goal
in any api
and what we as i mentioned might be a
tiny bit confronting i hope it's not
because there is no best api style
so if your api is mostly actions
then our pc is actually a brilliant
choice for us
but we shouldn't start saying i want to
build a grpc api
so a great example of a public rpc api
would be the slack api for instance
however if an api is mostly thought
or manipulating related data maybe with
a workflow
then rest is a fantastic choice
and mr sturgeon the person who i've
quoted here
um writes a blog um api's around tense
and he has a wealth of knowledge to
share in the subject
so i would encourage you to follow him
as well
and even one of the authors of graphql
lee byron stated that graphql is not the
optimal choice for all scenarios
it is very much focused on client server
where the clients or multiple clients
have very different data requirements
for server to server communications
there are better choices that's where
grpc
shines or thrift from twitter and even
any
rest apis in simpler cases as well
so again understand the context in which
so wrapping up api styles address
different
problem spaces in some cases
restless apis which i feel have been
responsible for
as well as a backlash against
rest apis would actually be better built
in
other styles not because those other
styles are
inherently better but some require
less of a ramp up time on behalf of the
development
and grpc is a perfect choice for
synchronous communication between
internal services
so where your domain requires very
frequent data updates
and potentially different interactions
rather
than the client server call that you
might see with the rest api
but supporting other scenarios such as
streaming data from the server where one
call from defined can result in
multiple responses from the server or
vice versa
where client streaming or in many cases
bi-directional stream
so again different styles and different
technologies support
the different areas of your application
so moving on to another comment that
was coming up quite often in sort of at
the start of last year it's dived down a
little bit
but there was this view that graphql
breaks
caching and the first question we should
really think about is what
type of caching because there's
many does it just universally break it
i'm not too sure so there's the client
side
so that might be in the browser or in
the case of graphql
in the denobilized client kit client
cache
there's on the server side also known as
application caching
or intermediary caching proxies such as
smooth
varnish or nginx so let's take a look
at this in a http context so
in addition to client and server side
you kind of intermediates which
will then be able to hold that data
between the clients and the server
reducing latency
and while you can do that for http
that's not an option for graphql or
jrpgc so while you can still handle data
other clients along the server
the intermediate options are not there
that's really about how they use http
across the wire
so posts for instance which are
typically used by
graphql are not cacheable by default
not by the individual boxes and why
could that be an issue
because while the speed of light is very
fast about 300 000
per second it's not infinitely so
so typically if you can get your data
closer to the point
they will get it faster
and where there's a will there's a way
um the graphql community have
looked at options about how to support
intermediary proxies and they've taken a
look to be able to use the get http
methods
along with persistent queries and
persistent queries was really
championed by apollo one of the vendors
or
producers in this area particularly in
the node space and that is instead of
the client sending
all the data to the server the entire
query rather that
query is stored on the server and then
just a query id is sent across
and then that query is hydrated on the
server before
and with that we can get back to using a
http
guest method but there's not a standard
around here which is a shame because
that was really what simplified a lot of
graphql
development instead of rest which was an
architectural style
and a lot of the implementation was left
to the development hence the
large ramp up time that i spoke about
previously
graphql eliminated a lot of that by
providing a
concrete specification to work from but
there is no graphql specification
for operating over http there are a few
unofficial ones but nothing that can
really bind the community
but it's not just about intermediary
proxies there's other
there's also other aspects to consider
authenticated traffic so for instance
any traffic with the authorization
header that might contain
a api key or a bearer token
will not be stored by default by
shared crashes
and if this is a case where all of your
data's personalized are tied to a
specific identity this change is a
problem the main
parts of this so maybe you wouldn't have
used intermediate proxies
at all so again consider that in your
domain that
whether the traffic is announced or
whether it's always served to a specific
client there's also other aspects such
as the more customizable you make an api
in other words the more power you give
to the client to define the data that it
needs
the less cachable it will become
so in restful you have slash customer
slash five that is very casual because
there's nothing else you can do with it
the second you make is more flexible you
are reducing the likelihood of the
caches
so wrapping up there's many different
kinds client server
and intermediate network be aware which
ones are powerful in your contents
highly customizable apis benefit less
from intermediate properties
and if they are valuable then rest is a
brilliant
choice and best practices are still
emerging for graphql
and grpc another comment which
i found quite um quite amazing was the
view that rest apis
are inefficient and what do we really
mean by inefficient
because in many cases rest was never
about short-term efficiency rather it
was
about longevity long-term evolvability
and evolution of a client and a server
which and tightly coupled together
so i think in many cases when we say
inefficient what we actually meant
was performance so that there was
performance issues
and typically this was the result of
over-fetching or
undefecting so over-fetching is where we
would retrieve
find more data than we required
potentially wasting expensive data plans
or under fetching where we have to make
multiple calls to the server to retrieve
the data that we
need yeah we have techniques for this as
well so we can use sparse field sets
to address overfetching or compound
documents such as defining json api or
hal hypermedia application language in
those media types to be able to type
multiple
responses together or representations in
a single envelope
and this is really where graphql was
first positioned and that was being able
to
allow any clients to retrieve exactly
the data into the single membership to
the server
however there's an implication to this
is that the slowest field now dictates
the overall response time
and this has always been the case with
any api but with graphql
giving all the power to the clients to
build up arbitrary depth
queries we are compounding that effect
quite a bit
so in fact all the data might come back
in a single call
but the time the client needs to wait
for all that data to respond can
actually be quite
fine and when i first started getting
graphql
apis into production that performance
tuning of queries became a significant
overheads to my teams
and again there's been certain movements
in the industry to try to overcome this
so using deferred queries where parts of
the data will be sent back to
the date to the client initially and
then http patches
for subsequent paths but it all adds
complexity
and what we really should be asking
ourselves now is should it be this
complicated should it really be this
hurt
and http 2 has really been a big game
changer in this area
with http 1.x we use many hacks
to try to overcome some of the cost
of a connection so be that the
the tns handshake or the tcp handshake
or windows scaling
needed but we ended up with typically
very poor
connection reuse and then the high cost
of a handshake quite often in our apis
whereas with http 2 we can have
long-last connections
and all of those communications between
the client and the server happening over
a single multiplex connection removing a
lot of that
cost of waste in doing multiple calls
so in fact looking at compounds
documents and in fact
being able to pull back all that data
and graphically well in a single poll
is very much a double-edged sword if we
could make separate calls
that didn't have a performance impact
then that's actually a far
better outcome for us because we still
get all
of the caching semantics we would want
from the discrete calls
but not the performance hit of making
multiple calls so it's a win-win
there's other aspects to http 2 as well
such as server push
and framework so open source projects
such as volcan
actually embrace server push to be able
to then have the server
proactively push additional
representations
to the client even without the client
asking
for it so again being able to if you
retrieve the master
automatically push the child resources
to the client
because the chances are they will need
it so that's quite a powerful approach
and while it never really gains traction
in the web space because prefetch links
with general
directors were generally easier to work
with it's showing a lot of problems in
the api space
so performance in http1.x the cost of a
handshake was very high
and that's both at the tcp level but
also at the tls
level and http removes the need for
compound documents
by actually reducing or avoiding the
multiple handshakes that would have been
required
and server push creates new
possibilities again
there's still certain issues with
efficiency and the fact that
all of those push representations live
within the http 2 connection
rather than the other um caches on the
browser
so again if that connection dies so does
that cache copy
and there's other aspects such as cache
digests that will
be able to allow the clients to say
don't push these because i already have
it
so it's still an emerging technology and
approach and
grpc heavily uses http 2
for that multiplex connections for the
streaming operations that it supports
but then does http 2 make graphql
irrelevant
so again if graphql was all about
compound documents supposedly
do we need it anymore and again graphql
is not just about network efficiency and
i feel we'll see as a community this
starting become less and less important
as we move forward
but the value of a technology is
actually the sum of its parts
so again as i mentioned before all the
other constraints it's not just about
the technology
it's about the ecosystem and the tool
and graphql offers an incredible
developer experience
you can get very good documentation out
of the box
using generation and it also comes with
a wonderful sdk
so we get how actually people consume it
and if you look at
an example for this in v3
of its api github had to support
multiple cloud libraries or sdks from
many different languages
with the power of a graphql
specification with v4
it didn't have to do that at all because
the community could build
graphql client libraries or sdks that
would then support
its api without having to do that work
themselves but also allows developers to
use that tool
of choice to never get excellent
developer experience
so when we're choosing a technology
think about all of the facets of the
ecosystem around
again the true value of graphql and many
technologies lies
in the in the two league ecosystem and
not just the
immediate technology itself if you're
only concerned
then with network efficiency then i hate
to end points might be a great
choice for that because compound
documents are no
are no longer the only option we have
for improving
network throughput but this story is far
from finished
another one of my favorites is graphql
supposedly eliminates the need for
versioning
however there was never a need to
version your api
it is a strategy for decoupling a client
from a breaking change in your api it is
a strategy
for compatibility not a requirement and
it's not the only option we have
available either
so we have versioning as being one but
we also have graceful evolution and when
vote fielding was asked how should you
version the rest apr
the simple answer was don't and in fact
this is exactly the same
view that the graphql designers
took as well favoring graceful evolution
through
the deferred attribute or directive
and to my mind gracefully evolution
should always be your goal
but it does require discipline so for
instance we can't add required inputs we
can't make outputs that were required
like
optional you can't remove them you can't
change the type of a field from a number
to a string
and we should always follow the
robustness principle of hostile's law
so be incredibly broad for what you
accept but incredibly specific
with what you said and this requires
discipline
and i guess the key thing there is don't
rely on grace and evolution alone
not over communicate with your users
around these changes
so it's not enough to say in my mind to
put
a deprecation or a sunset header in your
api responses
and then have your api consumers update
automatically
send those a bulletin let them know what
will change engage them let them know
how long the window is that you can
support them
particularly important when you're
building apis for internal teams in your
organization
but that still adds a lot to the
developer experience of making your api
a joy to use
and it's not just on the server side so
clients also need to have discipline so
tolerant reader pattern as defined by
martin fowler the enterprise
integration pattern book is again
how clients should respond to apis so
don't deserialize directly into classes
so if the fields appear in a different
order
don't worry if additional fields that
you aren't interested in
appear in the response again don't break
so apply the tolerance reader pattern
and that's what allows both the client
and the server to
evolve independently or more robustly
and graphql makes this an inbuilt
feature
so it makes deprecations to the
identification director
and when i first started using graphql i
thought this would be incredibly
powerful instead of doing broadcasts to
say
this field by change who'd be interested
who should i engage with
because i know every field that every
user is requesting
i'd be able to have specific
conversations what i found
though is it doesn't take long until
everybody uses something so you're
always
dealing with if you have to introduce a
great change really going through the
same steps you would have
anyway and it's not just about the
contract level
there's also certain in-built behaviors
in your api
about performance for instance which
while they're not defined in the
contract there's absolutely other people
relying on it
particularly if you've got multiple apis
that you might have
daisy chained together ignoring
multiplicative effective downtime
um and then latency becomes a big issue
across those services if you want to
choose the timeouts
so even if we're doing a refactor as
well of some of the behavior
in many cases understanding that you
shouldn't really fix or change a
behavior
and many of those behaviors cannot be
defined in the contract alone
so again communication with your users
becomes incredibly important
so how about we go about being able to
create our solutions that
can evolve racially and this is really
by
embracing the interface which in our
means a contract first
design so in graphql is the schema
it's the protocol buffer or again the
open api
etc definition and once we have that
shared understanding around the
interface
both the clients on the server team can
work independently using
mock stubs against that interface
finally you can integrate
and the whole loop repeats again so if
you're not using a contract first
approach particularly when you want to
be able to build things
in parallel i would encourage you to
investigate the approach
it is incredibly powerful to be able to
iterate a contract
very quickly rather than having all the
code that you need to change
so when you're designing your api the
later you can write the code with a
higher fidelity
the better outcome you're likely to have
with less friction
so versioning it's a technique for
managing braking changes
never a requirement you can do that for
any of the api styles
that you can support but again prefer
graceful evolution if possible but it
requires both the client and the server
to adopt those robustness patterns
absolutely not a substitute for
communication users
and it doesn't protect your users from
depending on implicit behavior
non-functional requirements
the final one we'll look at is domain
modeling is purely a risk
concern that's absolutely not
the case we have to embrace software
architects and design
and understand their domains
irrespective of the apis that
or the styles that we use and we should
always start with the users from the
bible right backwards so
what's the experience we need to provide
and then how might we go about designing
them
so again the contract is a great way to
be able to do this rapidly
and while both grpc
and and rest start with an outside-in
approach graphql changes this a little
bit whereby we build
a graph and then which depicts all the
data that can be queried
and then the client projects its queries
onto a certain portion
of that overall graph so the side effect
of this is graphql actually allows you
to delay the last responsible moment for
what the optimal queries are until the
users start using your system
so you don't have to iron out exactly
what endpoints they will have because
they can define the shape of their own
data
the trade-off with that is again
performance tuning gets pushed to the
right
in the process so api designs
so api design skills absolutely table
stakes irrespective of the style
you have to understand your problem
today both rest and grpc follow an
outside
design so start it with the experience
to find your end points to find your
operations in the case
of grpc and then work backwards
and graphql delays this moment until
profiling queries
so if you have a domain you don't have a
great understanding of potentially
multiple clients that need very
different data
rather than creating bespoke bffs or
different endpoints for each client
graphql allows you to support that in a
fairly elegant manner
albeit just that in my experience the
cost of
some of the the greater operational
overheads
so with those conversations understood
let's actually look at some sample
scenarios in the
final four seven options that we have
together and
look where i would be looking to apply
one of these styles
and the tendons i will always have as i
mentioned before
start with the properties and then work
backwards to the constraints
and one of those things always keeping
simplicity in mind so what's the
simplest approach that you could take to
solve this problem
rather than a technology approach trying
to pick the problem
so if you're just building a basic
application web form
maybe just a single client that web page
we use all the data and all we're doing
is posting it to the server
there is no value at all in using
anything more complicated than just a
simple
http post keep it simple
don't don't say but i might need more
functionality in future
that's fine it's very easy to change it
but keep your legs game as simple as
possible
both you and maybe the person who
supports the code base after you will be
thankful of that in the long run
where graphql does absolutely shine is
that that composite api
level so maybe you have a suite of apis
existing within your company
and maybe the many different
technologies and many different clients
requiring different data
and maybe there's multiple round trips
to the server and performance is an
issue
very much the same challenge that
facebook were facing when they were
creating graphql then graphql does give
you a second
chance to build the api you wish you had
built original
but it only gives you one chance that
can then act as a facade
to those downstream services but it does
not absolve you from really
understanding
what those data needs are but graphql is
absolutely agnostic
of the underlying data source it could
be another service it could be a
database it could be files it could be
another web service
but it does provide an incredibly
powerful
common interface into data whether that
data exists
on the client on the server you want to
interact with a speed
a real time or a request responsibility
type style
so having that single interface into
data particularly when you have
multiple different types of clients can
be very powerful
something i've been using quite a quite
a bit with my teams as well as
is the sort of the bff style
for from mobile apps so instead of
having manny d
normal many responses go back to the
client and having to stitch all that
data together really use a bff so
back ends for front-end pattern to
extend the application boundary to the
api
as well and grpc can really shine
in this area because what you can then
have is a
single technology that can support all
of the apis that you have so you can
have incredibly powerful code generation
for protocol files to find and then code
in
any number of modern languages and
having a very simple way of then
testing consistently across your entire
landscape
so we've seen that with certain clients
that then simplify their architectures a
lot
by being able to choose one style and
really optimize their teams for
how to build and release those apis
and again grpc is great when you have
highly
i would say temporary coupled apis
specifically microservices that all need
to exchange
data in a real-time basis and grpc again
is perfect for that
but there's certain scenarios which we
can support so for instance
grpc cannot be used natively
in a web browser we simply do not have
access
to the low level frames in a browser
that's required for
http 2. likewise we can't support
grpc hosted on asp.net app services
and we don't have access to some of the
trading headers that we need so even
though we can support htv too
there's certain aspects of that protocol
that are supported
so again what the industry have done in
this area have come up with a companion
protocol grpc way and that's effectively
a way of doing
grpc over http1.x
in a compatible way but if we're going
that from a client
you typically need a proxy that will
then convert the http 1.x
traffic to 2.0 for your internal
services
and typically that would be envoy
is what i've used before so the the
sidecar technology from istio which you
might be aware from it
but there's also experimental
technologies from
microsoft from james which allows you to
run
that on an app service without the need
for
a separate proxy
so again as i mentioned there is an
option there but it is experimental for
now rather than a finished product but i
do understand that microsoft
is intuitive so
takeaways you would have seen that
there's many different
api technologies and styles that have
evolved
over time while they appear very
different initially
they actually come back to a number of
core styles
each which supports or are aligned to a
certain set of problems
we then saw how you can start looking at
the properties of your system then
working back
to the constraints that would then help
deliver those properties or
characteristics
from there with that knowledge we can
start to look at some of the
conversations which are happening
in the community and then be able to
look at those statements
and then apply that constraint and
property thinking
to understand what's actually important
in your domain
and then finally we looked at just a few
real world scenarios which hopefully got
you thinking that maybe this is similar
to something that i've been building
myself
that will give you some guidance to be
able to understand where you should
start your journey
when you leave or get back to work from
agency oswald
so thank you so much for choosing my
talk this morning it's been
an absolute pleasure to be able to share
some of my experiences with you
if you're looking to um
download any of the slides they are
available
at this url once you download them you
will also gain access
to all of the resources that i used
in the creation of this talk as well
such that you'll be able to get that
next level of detail
as well so thank you so much for your
time and i hope you have a wonderful
remainder of abc oslo
thank you
you